you look gorgeous oh thank you thanks
for being here
uh it's very stressful for me like talk
shows because
this is my first one and i'm i'm worried
about my profile i don't like my profile
you don't like your profile
well hollywood is dominated by flat
faces
and so i was hoping we could do it like
more newscaster-y just like uh
just like more both of us yeah like
chelsea how are you i'm great conan we
should do the whole
this does feel like a weird experimental
dutch talk show
chancey how are you terrified why do you
not like your profile you have a
beautiful profile
thank you
i mean i guess you're right in a way
yeah
[Laughter]
no i i guess that joke doesn't play well
because i look like gisele bundchen
tonight
that always gets in the way doesn't it
no um no i'm very i'm uh just
i look when i get dressed up i feel like
the best i can hope for is people are
like
maybe she's a philanthropist
really no that's crazy talk very
beautiful woman
thanks i just wanted to keep doing this
as much as possible
yeah um no i'm very nervous i'm a
nervous person like dinner parties also
are
really stressful for me where i just
like that moment where everyone runs out
of stuff to say that's what i dread
yeah you know and i'll just fill in the
silence how much money does everyone
make you know
he's adopted who's adopted
you can't stand the silence you have to
jump in that's not good you got to just
relax
yeah it's going to be good it's going to
be fine now brooklyn nine-nine you got
to be that wasn't
watching you try to relax is really fun
uh
brooklyn nine-nine you guys won the
golden globe congratulations you won two
we won oh two oh oh
let's make it a three you won five
golden globes
yes yeah um yeah no life has changed
completely it's this crazy whirlwind now
where it's like i was on a flight
and there was this sweet old lady in
front of me and she
turned around her whole head like
craning craning around
is it cranning yeah training craning
okay i had it right
so smart and so she was turned around to
me and she was like
so sweet and she was like you're that
girl and i was like
yeah probably you know and she was like
i hate your show
she didn't say that she was like she
really say that she's like it's very
juvenile i i hate the writing and she
was smiling so sweetly
that's crazy and she had like wispy soft
hair which somehow added to it you know
just like you betrayed me with your hair
looking so gentle
yeah and she said she really said those
mean things to you
yeah and it's like you know when people
are mean on the internet and you're like
but no one would ever say this to my
face and then she did
i was like is this what internet trolls
are right
like it's actually sweet old ladies if
you got to meet them
they would just walk up to you and say
the most horrible thing yeah you're like
oh my god i know you from the internet
it's so awful like you can comment on
anything now you know it's like
i just feel like how is that going to
develop creative people's process if
it's just comments on everything you do
instantly like what if
einstein had been around in this time of
comment culture
as a little scientist just finding his
way just getting started yeah like just
figuring out cooking up some new
theorems
you might have gone on to some little
science website and just been like
e equals like i'm not sure yet you know
i'm still figuring it out as a young
scientist and then like the first
comment would have just been like
like what's up jufro
oh then einstein was just like i'm not
going to do science it's not worth it
yeah
we're losing a lot of scientists because
of the internet that's what's happening